hello guys Greg Alba here so I just
found out that Warner Brothers is
developing a live-action Nightwing movie
that's right Dick Grayson is coming to
the big screen once again it's been many
years you know since Batman and Robin
the Joseph gordon-levitt at the end of
The Dark Knight Rises doesn't count as
an official Robin in my opinion even
though his name is confirmed to be Robin
but you know that wasn't the sidekick to
Batman Robin that we all know I haven't
maintained a avid comic book reading
lifestyle over the past decade but when
I was really young like my early teens I
actually read a good amount of Nightwing
it was Batman and Nightwing I didn't
read a lot of different characters but
Batman and Nightwing are my two favorite
ones to read and Nightwing I would
probably say is my favorite one of all
the comic book characters for you guys
who don't know Nightwing my
understanding and I don't know if the
interpretation has changed over the
years but for the version I grew up on
it was Dick Grayson you know he became
Robin the Boy Wonder worked under
Batman's wing ha and as he grew older he
was growing more and more distant from
Bruce Wayne Batman and he wanted to do
his own thing he eventually split a
party and Dick Grayson moved to
blüdhaven where he eventually became a
cop by day and a vigilante
Nightwing at night and the reason I
really like Nightwing allotting
especially in comparison to Batman like
Batman to me bemmon it doesn't have the
greatest people skills when he's Batman
he's better at socializing when he's
Bruce Wayne but when he's Bruce Wayne
it's kind of a fake personality because
who he really is Bruce Wayne is more
really like is Batman and Batman can be
kind of controlling and manipulative
when he's mentoring someone and so it
grew a distance between him and dick
racing and Dick Grayson what I really
like about him as Nightwing is a lot of
Nightwing especially in the beginning if
you really like Nightwing year one or
even areas of the hunt for Oracle is a
lot of it is him trying to get away from
the Batman image and trying to establish
his own name and he keeps living under
Batman's shadow him Batman have this
distance but Batman still likes to
interject or help out even when he
doesn't really ask for it from bat
but the cool thing I like about
Nightwing is is can his personality is
very consistent whereas you know you
have Bruce Wayne's personality and then
Batman's personality I feel that Dick
Grayson he's pretty consistent when he's
just Dick Grayson without the costume in
the mask but when he's Nightwing he
still has the Dick Grayson personalities
there was a much more charming vigilante
I know Christopher Nolan Christian Bale
they talked a lot about how they don't
want to have a Robin in their Dark
Knight trilogy and despite whatever that
ending was or Joseph gordon-levitt and
saying his real name was Robin he wasn't
like the Dick Grayson or any of the
Robins we know from the comic book so it
wasn't an official adaptation of the Boy
Wonder I wasn't a huge Robin fan of the
comics but I really did grow to love
Nightwing a huge amount I loved the
world the blood Haven that he works in I
loved the idea that his job is that he's
a cop
and another thing I love different the
comics here that I'm hoping this movie
includes is the relationship he has with
Barbara Gordon where she's Oracle no
longer back to her and it would make
sense that for the current version of
the DC EU for them to introduce
Nightwing instead of Robin because if we
look at the timeline of things from what
have you seen from like BBS and such
where that one image of the Robin
costume with the Joker riding all over
it and flying and I think it was made
clear that that was actually Jason
Todd's costume so Jason Todd was the
second Robin meaning Dick Grayson had
already given up the Robin mantle and by
this point he should already be
Nightwing so it makes sense and in DC
you for them to not introduce Robin now
but to introduce Dick Grayson as
Nightwing and I feel like Dick Grayson
should be introduced as Nightwing
because having the Boy Wonder wouldn't
have made sense in the Dark Knight
trilogy and in the current DC EU having
dick racing the Boy Wonder
would it make sense either well what
does make sense is introducing him as
Nightwing where he's currently at in his
life and I feel like Knight we could add
a good flare to it you know like we're
talking a lot about how DC EU doesn't
really have a good sense of humor I feel
like you know Dick Grayson he doesn't
fall on her Deadpool comedy but he
definitely has more of a sarcastic sense
of humor he even when he's being a
vigilante he's he's still cracking jokes
while he's on these adventures and and
even the quips he has with Batman he's
constantly cracking jokes another thing
I love about Dick Grayson too is he has
his
gymnastics background he grew up in the
circus so he can do all these crazy kind
of flips and such I'm hoping that the
fighting style they incorporate for
Nightwing is that too similar of what we
see of Ben Affleck in BVS but also
incorporated a lot more fancy martial
arts moves as I feel like Dick Grayson
he's more skinny
he's more Airy allistic I think that's a
word and I think this is a great
direction to expand the DC EU because
we've already established metropolis for
establishing Gotham and now we can
establish Bludhaven I don't feel that a
Robin character unless it's like Tim
Drake I don't feel that a Robin
character will fit into the current
version of the DC EU but I feel like a
Nightwing character will definitely fit
in now for this director Chris McKay to
be doing it I really hope that he
doesn't go all dark and brooding about
this because one thing I really liked
about reading the Nightwing comics is
that there's a sense of humor even
throughout its villains and such
definitely Dick Grayson has a big sense
of humor and the guy who's directing
this is the dude who did Lego Batman
movie and I feel like you really
understands the Batman universe because
a lot of that movies a lot of jokes on
the Batman world so while that film was
a full blown animated comedy I really
feel like this guy actually has a good
grasp of the bat world and I hope you
won't be shy about infusing humor in
there because I found the Nightwing
comics to bring a smile to my face quite
often I think it's cool that you have
this established older more experienced
Batman who has a really intriguing past
I liked those characters where you could
feel a huge sense of history you know
like when we watched John wick that's
part of what makes John wick so cool is
that we feel this huge history he has of
all the crimes he's done all this hits
he's been on and same thing when you
watch Batman in the current version of
the DC EU you feel this major history
about him and now we can capitalize more
on that I've always thought that if you
were to add AB Nightwing into a movie I
feel like it would be cool if you went
off of my two favorite comics which is
Nightwing year one and Nightwing the
hunt for Oracle I feel like that's those
would be the best for world building
origin tale and I don't feel like they
should be shy about showing Batman a
little bit here and there in the
Nightwing movie one thing that I picked
up on a lot when I was reading the
comics was how Nightwing is constantly
trying to break
away from that man shadow and establish
his own identity I feel like having that
kind of character conflict would work
well for a Nightwing movie instead of
just trying to ignore the fact that
Batman exists in this world you don't
have to make it a Batman movie but I
don't think it would be a problem if you
have Batman making appearance a couple
of times in this film that's where who
should play Nightwing I don't really
have a lot of choices when I heard
Steven Yeun should be Nightwing I
thought that would be really cool I know
when the comics Dick Grayson is not an
Asian character I feel like it'd be a
cool opportunity to give a well-known DC
character because he's not like as big
as Batman or Superman
but I think he's popular enough I don't
feel like Dick Grayson being white is
super important to Dick Grayson so I'm
making him an Asian guy would be a cool
opportunity for this to branch out yeah
all in all I think this is a really cool
idea I think it makes sense to not have
Robin but Nightwing instead and I hope
that they take inspiration from like I
said my two favorite ones the hunt for
Oracle and Nightwing year one what do
you guys think of this Nightwing movie
in development if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects follow me on the Greg album on
Instagram and Twitter and I'm gonna
shoot more videos now wink